it's 20 21 it's january 6 and allegedly
i'm sleeping with kanye let me just say
this
one time for any news outlet uh i like
very tall men me and kanye uh have never
hung out and this whole thing is really
funny so
i guess if this is a start to my new
year
happy new year that's jeffrey starr
admitting he's
just as shocked as we are by those kanye
affair rumors
we bounce ideas we like to ask a lot of
questions jeffrey posted this video on
thursday titled
addressing the kanye situation where the
beauty influencer explicitly states he
did not hook up with kanye west
so i'm scrolling on the internet and
i read the dumbest [ __ ] i think i've
ever read my entire life
and the headline reads kanye west
might be sleeping with jeffree star
i can't i can't okay consider this rumor
debunked but how did it gain so much
momentum in the first place
let's start from the top
earlier this week new details emerged
about the state of kanye and kim
kardashian's marriage
following a report from page six so
just to fact check you guys et learned
that while divorce may not be imminent
for the couple
a source tells us kim has considered
divorcing kanye for quite some time
then came a tick tock that got this
whole rumor thread going
so i guess some girl made up a whole lie
on tick tock and it went
viral in the video with the initial page
six article as their background
tick tock user eva luis claimed reports
of kim and kanye's impending divorce
came as no surprise
because they've been holding on to
gossip for months
this whole divorce comes as no surprise
kanye's been hooking up with a very
famous beauty guru
male beauty guru a lot of people in the
scene have known for a while
yep no more no less that was the source
of the bizarre new couple report
but the gossip has also been fueled by
the fact that kanye and jeffrey
both own homes in hidden hills
california
and then i'm like how do we even get to
this moment like how how would that even
be made up because we both live in
the states right whatever in addition
kanye has been residing in wyoming for
the past several months
and jeffrey also just so happens to own
a home
in the state and jeffrey had a lot of
fun with this fact on
wednesday how did we even get to this
moment like how would that even be made
up because we both live in
the state right he posted these photos
to instagram writing
i'm ready for sunday service a reference
to the church services kanye has been
holding on sundays
in wyoming so i just woke up just trying
to live my life and i'm like huh
this is so weird i have people like
texting me all these news people
like what do you have to say about this
and i'm like about what
what i'm single i'm not sleeping with
anyone like this is so weird jeffrey's
message
certainly helps clear the air but it's
safe to say most people were never
really under the impression the viral
theory had
any truth to it and social media was
just having fun speculating with these
usual suspects in the pop culture gossip
but you guys i i really can't and if
chris jenner orchestrated his whole
thing
happy new year sweetie girl
you